last year you started tweeting and
basically took all of twitter tech
twitter etc by storm and i think a lot
of people at first were like ah who is
this guy is this gonna be an effective
um kind of avenue for a politician but
what we've seen throughout this year is
kind of the formation of this idea of
like the capital of capital and tons of
investment firms and asset managers all
coming to the city myself my brothers a
bunch of other people moving so maybe
just talk through a little bit as to
like what's happened over the last year
and how you evaluate where we are today
well you know it's interesting that you
say that because at the beginning you
know people were like well you know is
this a coveted thing uh is this
something that's gonna end uh during the
summer and then you know people are
often asking me you know what are the
analytics how do you prove
sort of this anecdotal story that you're
weaving you know through your own uh
podcast which are my cafe still tech
talks of which you and your wife
were a part of one and and now the
numbers are starting to come out and
they're starting to weave the narrative
in a way that is objective right so what
do i mean by that well in the last 16
months we've moved uh 1.1 trillion
dollars of assets under management
companies to miami okay in the last uh
the two quarters uh we have uh we have
we are number one in the nation in tech
job growth number one in the nation so
in the last six months uh we've we were
number one in the nation and tech job
growth i believe is 29 increase uh we
have created eight thousand jobs uh at
an average salary about 120 000 which is
just shy of a billion dollar recurring
annual economic impact so we're creating
uh high-paying jobs
uh and in the last five weeks or six
weeks we've closed uh about 550 million
dollars worth of venture capital deals
which annualized is is about uh you know
it's it's approximately a six billion uh
a six billion dollar uh you know deal
flow which is which is basically uh a
200 percent increase pro pre pandemic in
addition to that we got the bitcoin
conference from los angeles which was
hugely successful 50 000 people uh
conference uh you know and and we've
gotten ftx uh to sponsor the arena we've
got an xbto to sponsor uh you know our
soccer team into miami uh etoro open an
office in miami blockchain.com opus
opening office in miami so we're not
only weaving ourselves into a capital
capital narrative but we're also weaving
ourselves into a bitcoin capital of the
world narrative and that's what i'm very
proud of
and so when you think about this idea of
like local governments in the digital
age i think that there's been so much
focus on national politics and and kind
of geopolitical uh topics uh people had
almost forgotten about the local
governments right for most folks i think
uh they kind of had this uh dissonance
between uh i think a lot about who the
president is i think a lot about who the
elected officials are on the national
level but actually some of the most
important things are what happened to me
locally right and the rules and
regulations and just the general
posturing of those local politicians so
maybe talk a little bit about how you
see the role of those local governments
in this new digital age
well the way that i explain in the sort
of the way i read the miami story is i
talk about three things specifically you
know i talk about the fact that we have
under my watch the second lowest tax
level since the 1960s which is a
property tax it's the only tax that we
impose
number two while other cities in america
have decided to defund their police
when and have seen crime increase we
have increased funding in our police and
our new budget
calls for over 30 new police officers um
we're in the process of negotiating with
our labor unions and hope to have a new
labor deal with them so we're increasing
funding for our police department and
we've seen historically low levels of
crime uh just a couple years ago we had
the lowest homicide rate since 1954. and
then the last thing is we're focusing on
quality of life because one of the
things i've learned i'm 43 years old in
my life is the one commodity you can't
get back you can't trade you can't get
more of it's time and so
you know we invest and we do all these
things so we can have the ability to do
what we want with our time and so if you
design a city around that fact
and you focus on you know cultural
facilities of which we continue to
invest in if you focus on parks we just
did a 100 million dollar linear park
called the underlying you focus on
sports uh we have uh all the major
sports plus formula one that's beginning
next year they just did a 10-year deal
where the only the second city in
america has formula one and we're the
only city that has all the sports and
formula one probably in the world
and then you talk about homelessness
which is another quality of life issue
we have 510 homeless in our city we're
at the lowest level since 2013
and we just got passed through our
dollars or what i call a functional
homeless plan which is to hopefully be
one of the first big cities in america
uh to to reduce homelessness to zero so
that is is is sort of the
the importance of local government how
it touches on all of those aspects of
your life your quality of life and i
think uh you know i think that is
important for people to realize federal
government is obviously your federal tax
dollars your income tax and how that's
spent on national security uh as social
security and welfare uh or things of
that nature um you know social programs
uh and and your state is mostly a state
income tax which is a consumption tax um
but the city are the ones that pick up
your garbage they police your streets
and and they keep you safe and protected
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more the best business show we're going
to build the biggest business show in
the world and we need your help
[Music]